and we sat on them in the Oslo Esports
oh they are so comfortable yeah I want
to well Duda begins with the D and he's
pushed his Depot and two squares forward
and are we gonna see something are we
gonna see I was gonna say pregnant I
push the E Pawn on the G Pawn so we see
Prague push the E Pawn and now block
things up so it's transposed into the
Catalan this is actually what they
played earlier in game one of the day
still They're copying that game who has
done their homework better white blocks
a check this is still following the
lines of that earlier game between the
two that do the one he got an opening
advantage in game one of today so I'm
really fascinated to see where prague's
Improvement is look at the evaluation
bar as well it quite likes white the
computer preferring white at this early
stage already Prague Must Have Spent the
break time that 10-15 minutes that the
players have between games looking at
this with his coach Ramesh is probably
then San Fran right now just with a
computer saying hey this is what you
should play this is where you should
improve and this is how top players
prepare nowadays and meanwhile black
defending a pawn
and uh it's up to Duda at will he can
regain his opponent in the Catalan often
you sacrifice temporarily just to open
up White's light squared Bishop so it's
all about the tension between this let's
go Bishops right now it's also quite
reminiscent of uh Magnus in that last
game Liam against Carlson the pawn
structure is almost identical yeah wow
and that last bishop move has been the
change that Prague has made I was just
checking in the first game uh Prague
actually pushed the a pawn two squares
forward to defend the B Pawn here
Duda is on his own now
so we have the first Improvement as we
call it the first Innovation I'm not
sure if it's a novelty in general in the
history of Chess but at least in the
clash between these two uh novelty
according to my database now my database
isn't necessarily the most comprehensive
but uh we're going to take its word for
it we love Novelties yep brand new move
this position never been seen before and
that's why dude has got that face right
now frowning uh wondering what the
difference is this is very logical black
protector Pawn black develops a bishop
so surely in his opening preparation he
should have examined this move should
have come across it or at least
considered it
it's uh yeah Prague will be feeling
confident that he got the first surprise
in often that's just the key no matter
when your novelty is as long as you get
the first idea in you surprise your
opponent first and will he be aware it's
the novelty pragnananda will this be
something he has prepared yes it's
something either that he prepared
himself or his coach told him to do and
his coach will have explained why it was
such a strong move or why this move
order was slightly more accurate than
the move order he played in game one
where he got in a bit of trouble prag
so maybe it's Duda who's unaware whether
it's a novelty or whether it's uh just
prag freestyling yeah and it's a
different plan as well because in that
first game Prague was actually lifting
The Rook on A8 and moving it to the
seventh row and Swinging it across here
he's just saying okay I'm taking a
different approach which is simply to
return the extra pawn and I'm going to
focus on developing the pieces here and
black will focus on developing the
pieces let's maybe show where the
novelty was the brand new move doesn't
look that special but it looks very
sensible at least was to play this one
in that earlier game Prague immediately
pushed his phone his Pawn forward and as
Ivanka mentioned after White's Rook came
across Black's Rook lifted up this one
does look a bit odd uh what he did in
game one uh he wanted to shift the Rook
across maybe but uh his move now at
least looks far more sensible he moves
the bishop and what uh the black idea
here is all based upon the fact that
White's two pieces here cannot get into
the game so for example white can regain
a pawn white can take this undefended
Pawn either with his queen or with his
Knight say he takes with the Queen the
issue is long term even if white gains
material uh over the next few moves
these two pieces how are they ever going
to develop you can't get your Rook out
unless the Knight moves but the Knight
can't move because at the moment this
Pawn dominates the Knight it controls
the two squares that the Knight can jump
to to develop so white actually has to
take a timeout at some point Duda for
example he might need to maybe even in
the current position might need to move
his Bishop back just to create this
Square for the Knight to jump to and if
he can jump out then he breatheses
breathes a sigh of relief
but yeah dude it needs to be a bit
clever with his development Prague is
playing against those two pieces this is
very modern chess as well often you
don't care about Pawn's material you
just care about peace activity in modern
chess and that's these two pieces oh
yeah I agree with you David My Vibe was
actually to retreat the bishop right now
and just contort yourself on the back
row I call it back row chess whenever I
have to play like this in my notes I'm
like yeah living on the back Rank and
there we see Prague develop his Queen
and I'm fully expecting the White Knight
to also take a step forward to move to
D2 so that it can capture on C4 yeah and
prague's whole idea as well is that the
Catalan the opening that white has
chosen is all based on this light
squared bishop and how strong it is on
the diagonal so Prague wants to swap it
off uh if if white does indeed move his
Knight then black will take the time to
push upon and he's going to trade off
whites of Pride and Joy if this bishop
disappears then White's King actually
becomes a bit open on the light squares
later on so I do like what Prague is
doing I think he's prepared really well
I agree it's a good preparation and it's
it's a sign of confidence as well to
repeat exactly the same opening that you
played and lost in the first game
against the very same opponent as well
so there you see Prague rocking in his
chair and he captures the pawn with the
queen and here comes the breakout anyhow
yep so this is actually a pawn Sacrifice
from Prague he's willing to give up a
Pawn One Moment who's a pawn up he's
about to be a pawn down but the only
goal is to trade off those light squared
Bishops if black hadn't broken out now
he might never have broken out he would
have been kept in a bind forever
so I really like it it's clearly been
approved by the computers the fact that
Prague is playing it so quickly and this
is also the benefit of having a coach on
site Ramesh during game one maybe even
during game two was just sitting there
with a computer analyzing preparing
finding where uh prayer could have
improved and this is it it's now move 17
and Prague has played each one of his
moves instantly and he's given up a pawn
but now he's going to try and regain it
the black Rook now is eyeing up that
White Queen yep there's actually no way
that white can hold on to that extra
Pawn I mean I was thinking if you
Retreat the night then black is simply
going to add more fuel to the fire and
attack the pawn again yeah this is
looking like excellent preparation from
pragnananda yeah and I think he's gone a
lot deeper dude is frowning here maybe
he's surprised and to be honest uh I
would be a bit surprised too that black
is playing so quickly you mentioned that
uh White has one extra Pawn here and uh
can you keep it intact If you defend it
with the Knight as you mentioned Ivanka
then Black's Knight one of the two
knights can come and just grab this Pawn
next move uh this Pawn is doomed you're
attacking it three times now it can't be
defended but the question I would be
asking myself is what happens if white
steps forward with this Pawn because it
is defended on this Square
black queen is attacked you can't take
this Pawn yet at least I don't think so
so you would have to move the black
queen we'll do to go for this I think he
will when the black queen moves maybe
this is Craig's idea that the White
Knight is a bit unstable in the center
but it still requires kind of
understanding and knowledge over the
next three or four moves black still
needs to be accurate to win this Pawn
back later because if this Pawn survives
White's gonna win the game this Pawn is
too strong
to only two squares away from promotion
maybe his idea later is to use the Rook
as well to come and take this Pawn later
uh yeah I think it's just a battle about
this one Pawn on C5 if it survives what
is winning if it drops black is at least
equal yeah and uh White does also has to
be very careful that in the battle to
preserve that extra Pawn they don't make
too many positional concessions because
once black does in fact win the ball
then White's position could collapse
yeah it's not just two bad pieces now
that we talked about that were
undeveloped but white has made his
Bishop bad just to uh create a knight uh
square foot at night White's Bishop
takes a long long time to get in the
game it's just staring at a wall of
Pawns over here on this diagonal it's
not a great piece so you're right Ivanka
if white can't find anything Direct
then he's got to be really careful about
timing if everything gets traded off for
example if white does take a negative
decision like retreating which isn't due
to style so I'd be surprised if this
happens then suddenly after the Knight
jumps say again if white develops
suddenly Knight takes porn and we'll see
a situation where
after the White Queen moose black is
better because white has one really
really bad piece and uh okay Duda
doesn't of course step back and start
retreating not his style uh he offers a
queen trade instead
interesting decision if the Queens
disappear then suddenly this white Rook
which wasn't developed we said it was a
bad piece it has come to life on an open
file it has targets for example that
would be a really nice tactic here
actually this should go down in the
books when we talk about pinning if
Bishop takes porn white can win on the
spot by playing Bishop takes pawn it
looks like this black pawn was defended
but white is pinning black on this line
and on this line so this bishop is
poisoned it's Untouchable if you take it
with a pawn you lose your rook in the
corner if you take it with the bishop
sorry in this position if you take it
with a black Bishop you lose your Rook
on the C file so uh double pins this is
something you nearly never see in chess
a double pin to win the game I've
actually never seen something like that
and I can tell you when you make a move
of such Brilliance you also have a big
smile just like the chest or just like
Yankee stuff Duda uh when he played that
amazing checkmate so that's a beautiful
spot David we know Duda likes to smile
at his own moves so uh Prague will try
and stop that so we do think that Queen
takes Queen is a mistake because it
opens up this white rook in the corner
and therefore I'm expecting uh Prague
he's out of his preparation now first
think of the game but I'm expecting him
to dodge the queen exchange something
about the sort of the symmetry of your
two pins there on the analysis board as
well beautiful chess art yeah this
position now it's definitely diagram
worthy in a book yeah it's uh yeah I
don't think we'll see Prague before for
that trick yeah probably not but it
would be kind of fun it would be kind of
fun we do have a lot of drama going on
today day five in the tour finals two
players are in must win situations one
of them is Anish giri sitting in San
Francisco together with Prague there he
has to win game three here against Arjun
erag icy to take it to a game four and
so does shakria or mama diarov he is
down by two points against Wesley so who
has had a fantastic day winning both of
the first two days and we're gonna hear
what Wesley said after winning game two
Wesley a two-point March lead looking
good effed yesterday I think whoever
wins the first game has a huge advantage
of like an 80 chance to win I must say
because the players here
all very strong they're very evenly
matched uh maybe except Magnus
so uh it's when you look at the first
game it's just psychologically mentally
very difficult to come back I mean I
don't know what Chuck's thinking but I
think I have a pretty good shot winning
this match speaking of coming back shark
tried it and this game with the white
pieces we saw a creative H4 H5 early
advance but you kept everything under
control and played it out super calmly
yeah it's nice first of all I didn't
expect him to play the English I thought
you'd play his usual one before
and you know prepare some deep
preparation stuff just like in game one
uh
uh I guess once before I usually play E5
but if I have been testing c5s quite a
bit and I think though his theater
Bishop D2 is just uh over the board
inspiration like I think white you
should Place H4 instead of B3 and white
thumb chances there but little bit of
detailing overboard inspiration I'm not
sure
I mean at least I was very happy to get
a playable position and not lose right
out of the opening like against like one
but um
yeah basically we got a very complicated
position so he got exactly what he
wanted
um but at the same time I wasn't I don't
think I was that worse and when the
queens were traded I was very happy
because then we get quite an equal end
game I'm not sure whether his move H6
was correct I mean he could delay that
move he has several tempting options
such as hg6 or
you've been castling Along on some lines
and I'm also cast along but yeah it's a
nice game yeah you seem to have shut
down all the counter player after that
Queen trade game three coming up I want
to ask you Wesley what's the approach
for the next one I'll try to get that
draw in one of the two games
loving the honesty good luck
he is a fun guy Wesley so and the bar
has been definitely over to his side uh
almost the whole time in this game three
so it's not very unlikely I guess that
he's gonna get that draw in game three
no I mean if someone can lock the game
down and secure a draw without too much
trouble it's gonna be Wesley he has this
incredible talent for getting draws when
he needs to he's so pragmatic and whilst
the players are thinking we do see that
uh Duda has gone into sorry Prague has
gone into a very deep things five
minutes I know you know he's been
certainly surprised by that queen queen
move from Duda well
we do have some people who have taken up
our challenge so we're asking today can
you beat Magnus Carlson's score you know
we're asking you to download the app
from the Magnus chess Academy and play
the game Ace in the sleeve and uh
Patrice Gluck says that they are on
level that there are 39 on level 12.
they ask when can I play Magnus
and battery goes even one better says
yay 42. wow that's odds
Magnus better than Wesley finally able
to beat magnus's score it's 3am here and
hopefully I'll go and get some sleep now
we have to be Alpha zero to be a niche
in this wow that's impressive yeah it's
very impressive but it's possible this
is your chance to beat world champion
Magnus cross and that's something chess
related the Ace in the sleeve game
inside the Magnus chess Academy app I'm
so impressed first by making it to level
12. that's going to take me a long time
and second of all beating magnus's score
of 39 cards in that game wow and we knew
we had some very strong viewers uh some
great chess players out there watching
our show but yeah that's another level
beating beating Magnus and beating
Wesley I thought Wesley would be very
good he's great with the pattern
recognition former fresher random world
champion yeah impressive stuff yeah
Prague also did good in this he's great
like that right frag yeah we saw when we
set David's impossible puzzle yeah that
he was like yeah yeah it's Queen A8 yeah
five seconds
even though the rest of us had to
actually rack our brains and think very
hard I love puzzles like that and I I
can't quite remember when it was great
when when that puzzle was composed but
it was I think it was composed by Sam
Lloyd one of the most famous chess
composers of puzzles and he he does the
most he does some fantastic puzzles wow
if anyone wants to also solve as many
puzzles as possible then I would check
out him
cool Sam Lloyd chess I'm going to put
that into Google later Sam Lloyd chest
fossils how cool
chest fossils are fun and the chess apps
are from the new Magnus chess Academy
app is just a fantastic app for
improving your chess and having fun with
it just playing some really cool chess
related games Prague is thinking again
for a long time he is ticking down on
the clock we're gonna go to San
Francisco we're probably sitting and
where Tanya is our roving reporter
what's happening Tanya
I can't agree with you more between the
games and the interviews that's pretty
much all we're doing here in the mix
Zone on the app Ace in the sleeve that's
the game everyone wants to be on right
now but for now we have another very
special guest with us it is yuyanga she
is an economist and a chess player and
in her life chess has played a big role
oyanga welcome to the show it's so nice
having you with us thank you so much I'm
so excited to be here yeah tell us a
little bit about the role of Chess
you're from Mongolia now you're at UC
Berkeley what role did chess play chest
was such a profound role in my life
because you know I started playing like
very little when I was in Mongolia and
then I immigrated to us you know and
that was such a different environment
and I started playing chess and started
tournament and even teaching chess in
the US which like enabled me you know to
overcome so much like challenges here as
an immigrant and uh support you know
support me with pursue my dream and
Academia eventually so yeah one of the
things with the tour has been how chess
just makes the world a small place it
brings everyone together from different
parts of the world over the game have
you seen chess break barriers in your
profession
um in in economics you made yeah
definitely so
um yeah like in economics also in chess
you know it's a very mean and dominated
Sport and especially being a woman in
economics and chess has like has been
challenging in a way but um it has been
definitely very a profound experience
yeah you were in quinoa as well uh tell
us about that experience as a Scholastic
program yeah and that was an incredible
experience I was here I was in Kenya in
Africa for work and I was able to visit
some of the Scholastic chess tournaments
there and kids were just very
enthusiastic about the game and I was
able to give some speeches and like play
simul games and just see how also like
play chess plays a role in school
programs
um and some of the schools you know I
want to do eventually want to do
research on how you know we can do chess
programs in schools and to see how that
changes kids lives you know in academic
and non-academically and in your
experience what's been the most profound
way in which chess has changed people's
lives
um like it's a like you said earlier
chess is a you know different kind of
world and just for me like people I met
through chess has been incredible
um asset for my life and some of the
people I met completely changed my life
yeah wow and are you having fun here
today at the door absolutely it's been
such a pleasure to be here yeah so much
fun what's it been like watching the
players come by stop for the interviews
enjoying the app yeah definitely because
I actually never seen for example Magnus
Carlsen in person before so I've been
really enjoying and able to watch their
games in the same room so it's been very
special yeah who are you rooting for
here
um
Magnus Carlsen and also Wesley cell I
like I like him too yeah awesome thanks
a lot there we have it Wesley and Magnus
lots of fans here lots of fun going on
here in San Francisco
oh I bet you guys are lucky to be on
site with uh these four players We are
following the game between Prague and
Duda they are tied after two games and
Prague has been spending a lot of time
over the last few moves but we do have
some moves on the board now we do have
some moves on the board and Prague has
won his Pawn back now he's just deciding
how to recapture this Intruder this
White Knight on C5 and the Mystery to me
and I think you mentioned as well uh
Ivanka we were just discussing that
why is white better why is the
evaluation bar on white side it looks
like Prague has a perfectly playable
position I I agree I mean I was thinking
okay if he captures with the queen I
mean why does the computer love White's
position so much especially because the
bishop or the bishop that black has kind
of actually defend any potentially weak
Pawns so big mystery yeah big mystery he
looks like White's Bishop if anything is
just the worst piece on the board so how
can white hope to have an advantage uh
Prague I'm not sure about the queen
exchange I've got to be honest I think
he could have taken with the bishop as
well kept the Queens on the board if he
wanted to be more Dynamic but uh yeah it
looks like he should be fine here
now again a question does he recapture
the White Queen with the black Rook with
the black Bishop there's arguments to be
made for both he takes with the bishop
this makes sense you don't really want a
rook trade because white still has a
blocked in Rook in the corner White's
Rook doesn't want uh you don't really
want to allow it to get into the game
but meanwhile the evaluation bar
continues to shift up for white so big
big mystery here in the studio maybe we
can jump into show why uh here I mean
what could be more natural take back the
queen with the bishop the computer says
Nope mistake but uh is it do you Banker
with the Knight coming to this Square
maybe yeah I think so to attack this
pawn it has to be that move because
after all I mean you can't step back
with the bishop in order to defend it so
you have to instead but that's sorry
because of Knight takes Bishop yeah and
just a show at the very end after a
bunch of exchanges there would be a
Checkmate and uh if black can't step
back as you say
yep and uh Duda playing the direct move
then if you can't step back with the
bishop that means you have to defend
that pawn with the Rook and sometimes I
just use maths to assess the position
I'm like hey a knight is traditionally
worth three a rook is worth five three B
three is less than five so therefore
white is better just on the basis of of
who can use their pieces in a better way
yeah so essentially white tonight we'll
stay here attacking this pawn and
Black's Rook which is the more important
piece is also stuck here defending this
weakness and those two pieces balance
each other out the rest of the army
though it's still hard to imagine white
being too much better just because of
this bishop I'm looking at this bishop
I'm saying where is it coming out maybe
long term the computer its Horizon will
see that white can step forward with a
pawn no matter what black does White's
Bishop will come to this Square again
let's say black makes a move finally the
bishop breaks three you push upon
forward and once these two get exchanged
you suddenly look at the pieces and you
think oh yeah maybe now white is indeed
better uh White's Knight isn't isn't an
outpost after all it is eyeing up this
backward weak pawn and uh black snide
still takes a few moves to get into the
game to be honest I still feel like a
draw would be quite likely here but
maybe I mean this is the only
explanation I can come up with for the
evaluation bar being on duda's side yeah
I I have to say I'm equally puzzled
David and uh Prague wow he doesn't even
bother to defend that pawn I thought
that was a must so what tactics does uh
Prague up have up his name has he just
lost a pawn I mean surely Duda can just
take this what could be going wrong for
white here everything's protected
everything else for white is on the back
rank pretty safe
so practicing an active way of Defending
remember he is the king of
counter-attacks so what is he trying to
counter-attack if white just grabs on A5
he goes a pawn up he's not just any old
pawn as well it is a past Pawn now
computer thinks white can get away with
being greedy
I don't get it I mean I mean presumably
the Knight is going to spring forward to
the E5 Square I don't really know what
it's doing David yeah and it looks like
it's coming in but those aren't too
threatening for example if white just
Waits if you give a check White's King
just moves I don't think you really want
to trade off for this really bad Bishop
if you come the other way yeah The Rook
just moves and I think you're pretty
safe yeah I have a confession I just I
don't understand
yeah I think we've given up trying to
understand this game because uh White is
just one upon Duda did get greedy he did
grab the pawn on A5 so he's a clear
Point ahead a very important Point ahead
and uh Prague did indeed jump into the
center but unless Prague has seen
something that we don't or the computer
doesn't see it just looks like these
night jumps they're just Illusions
they're just kind of visual tricks they
look active these night jumps but they
don't do anything they don't achieve
anything
and maybe that's one small weakness
still in prague's game that he doesn't
want to defend passively ever sometimes
you need to make exceptions and you need
to defend uh if we go back this night
move yes it's on the cards yes you want
to activate the Knight later you want to
reroute it but first you maybe just need
to take a step uh maybe oh Ivanka I
think I've spotted why he didn't do this
it's that pin again the pin we mentioned
from earlier the mystery has been
resolved Knight takes Pawn was still
possible because after The Rook
recaptures Bishop takes Pawn suddenly
this bishop comes to life and this is a
pin
oh this is the idea this pin wins the
game for white uh because now the
blackrockers attacked and if the Rook
moves you win the bishop you come out
two pawns up so we have resolved the
mystery after thanks good job you guys
it took us a while it took us a while
but uh these players that's why they're
so good they see these things quicker
than us they see these things instantly
so maybe there was a defense the
computer thought black could maybe hold
but uh Prague didn't find the best way
instead now he lost this pawn and he has
to hope that he can find some miraculous
compensation uh there the computer is
skeptical I'm very skeptical too I do
feel with good technique Duda should be
able to finish this game off and he
Retreats his Knight very sensible just
yeah trying to trade off pieces one up I
must admit when you showed that uh
tactic you know the bishop takes the
pawn I felt like doing a Life of Brian
moment
it took me too long I missed it the
first time though but the worst was that
you actually showed it to us yeah a few
moves ago that's why that's why everyone
needs to download that app because uh
this tactic that we just saw uh here I
mean we showed the same pattern earlier
sorry in this position we showed the
same pattern with this pin and uh we
forgot it the second time so that's why
we need to hammer home practice practice
practice these patterns with apps like
that one yeah Magnus chess Academy that
is the app to practice stuff like this
and it's looking good for you on Chris
to do that this is game three against
fraggy through wins it he will take the
lead two matches Wow have already
finished it's a match win for Wesley
Seoul winning also game three against
Muhammed Yaro to take all three points
and it's over also for a new sitting in
San Francisco a draw in game three means
he loses the match Arjun or Galaxy takes
all three points in that one as well
still too much is going on this one will
definitely go to a game four and so well
Magnus calls against Liam
I think maybe the bar is slightly over
to Liam's side they are tied winning one
game each so far Magnus losing his first
game of the tournament in round two here
against Liam Lair is he in trouble at
all in game three it looks Possible Oh
Magnus he's taken some significant risks
he's actually two pawns down in that
position uh he has the bishop pair we
know Magnus is great with Bishops he won
yesterday against Anish giri in a
position where he had two Bishops so I'm
not going to write him off but Liam
looks like he's fighting very well at
the moment and we could see some big
surprises and some real real uh
turnarounds
for the leaderboard especially yeah that
would be really shocking actually if
Liam Lowe were to win his match against
Wesley so Wesley so her Magnus carlsa I
jumped ahead of the gun because I was
going to say he also beat Wesley so he
stole points from him and uh and Duda
yeah
incredible stuff you guys said if this
happens if Magnus now loses game three
chances as David says for the MLA in
that game and you know wins this game
against uh probably the bar way over to
his side wow it's gonna be an
interesting game four today and it's
gonna be a very interesting weekend with
Duda and Magnus fighting to win
the finals and even Liam
getting in there
yeah it's open even Wesley so he's only
going to be three points behind and all
of the top guys play each other in the
final two days so even Wesley imagine he
lost his first two matches of the
tournament and he's catching up now he's
in it now oh a lot of fun you guys but
we are following this game Duda still
with five minutes on the clock
is this an easy win or will it take some
thinking take some thinking especially
now because Prague his testing due to
the Limit this last move I must have wow
look at Duda not happy at all uh maybe
he's calculating maybe he's not upset
but uh he must have missed this last
move I must admit I'd missed it uh here
we did see Black's Knight and the white
Bishop disappear so that exchange is
actually beneficial for white white has
a very nice night now against Black's
Bishop if black was too slow if he
played any other move on the board for
example pushing a pawn white would
cement his Knight on this Outpost now
the Knight is here for eternity and
White's Pawn would start marching
forward
meanwhile though Prague did test Duda
and Duda I think has passed this test
because the black Bishop moved into the
center giving itself up but trying to
dislodge this white knight trying to win
the white knight uh but instead of
getting tempted instead of taking the
black Bishop allowing the black Rooks to
get active allowing the beautiful white
knight to disappear uh Duda just
realized he could play it calm he could
play it safe and this Knight is attacked
why not just defend it now the black
Bishop has to retreat has to run away
and next move I think duda's plan is to
cement the Knight this formation of
Pawns and night now
they're going to win the game if all the
Rooks disappear you're winning the end
game no matter what you just keep this
one up your sleeve any future end game
is winning for white because of this
protected platform yeah and uh you take
control of the open line take control of
d-line and White's King is primed and
ready for the action so fantastic
position for Duda and it was a nice shot
by a Prague but it wasn't good enough
yeah it was a nice try to try and trade
off the bishop for night but now you are
stuck in a sad situation of a good night
versus bad Bishop Black's Bishop even if
it Parks itself on an outpost like this
one it doesn't do anything it just hits
thin air white can play around this
bishop on the light squares Duda I think
is Big favorite now
oh it's getting uh dramatic and fun in
the tour finals you guys this is round
five out of seven
and Duda he is putting pressure now on
Magnus Carlsen sitting in the same room
as pregnant on the Magnus Carlson now
fighting in game three against Liam we
will of course jump to that game when
this one finishes if it's still going on
of course
just laughing because we suddenly saw
the webcam of Duda yeah and he just
looked a little bit evil there was like
Shadows all over his face okay now he
looks uh back to his usual self and uh
yeah he's in full Focus mode he knows
what needs to be done and uh Paul Bragg
it was such a good opening but somehow
other it didn't work out well for him
yeah and we did praise prague's opening
choices he was the one to launch the
first surprise the first novelty but if
he does fall to defeat he'll have lost
two games in the same opening that's
true in the same variation of the
Catalan so yeah there's an argument for
maybe mixing it up even if you go deeply
and kind of even if you prepare further
than your opponents
the type of position doesn't suit your
style you will still uh yeah you will
still be suffering as we see and he
found a counter-attack again a move that
wasn't on my radar Ivanka it wasn't on
mine either and uh well here comes the
counter-attack wow these two guys has
just surprising us on every turn
tactical monsters they're both so good
the problem for Prague though is he's
about to go two pawns down and uh he
will lose the game he did test dude
again we have to show what just happened
because it was quite spectacular uh I
thought Duda had already calmed the
waters I thought he would just face a
bishop Retreat then Duda fixes these
pawns remember this formation is winning
for white but uh Prague no he plays an
interference tactic he push pushes his
Bishop in the middle breaking the
connection of The Rook at night but the
bishop wasn't captured if portex Bishop
the White Knight Falls this would have
led to maybe some drawing chances for
Prague but instead the White Knight
leaps out the way and remember Bishop
takes Rook is bad here because when all
the Rooks come off the board White's
Pawn will win the game this would have
been deadly so uh unfortunately for
Prague this wasn't possible he had to
move his Rook out the way and after Pawn
takes Bishop look at this as well
Black's back rank is the main floor in
his position you cannot go and take this
port now if you could you might draw but
unfortunately a check and you're trapped
on the back rank so he should have given
his King some breathing space earlier he
gives his King some breathing space now
but uh White now has two connected past
pawns they survive and they're about to
win the game
too too late and uh Duda offers a trade
of Rooks frag will be forced to say no
we'll have to slide his Rook over to the
A2 square but there you go it's on the
board but dudo's just going to do the
same he's just gonna lift his rook and
challenge the black rook and it's
nothing to be done yeah just those two
pawns they're just so strong they will
walk themselves down to the Finishing
Line yeah we see a bit of a dance
between the Rooks the white Rook is
saying please take me please trade off
black is saying no and we're seeing the
Rook Shuffle across but eventually Duda
as you say Ivanka he's just going to
find the right room to start pushing
those two pawns forward what I would do
here I would just keep things simple I
would put both white Rooks behind the
two white pawns so one Rook behind the a
Pawn One Rook Behind the B Pawn and then
just propel them forward I was gonna ask
to what is your tip when a beginners
have sort of two pawns and they know
they can March them to the other side
there's Rooks on the board is that the
way to do it that's the key rook's
behind passports whether you have
connected past pawns or whether they're
even separated as long as your Rooks are
behind then the opponent's Rook will be
a blockader and it will be passive if if
you imagine The Rook swapping places so
blacks Rooks were behind and white
trucks were in front White's Rooks would
actually be in the way they would be
passive but uh so if you're attacking
you want Rooks behind past pawns if
you're defending you also want your Rook
behind the opponent's passports but
unfortunately for Prague one of his Rook
is stuck on the side one is stuck at the
top I I wasn't expecting that little
Rook move from Duda I was expecting the
pawns to start walking but uh no rush
I like I like this move calm and steady
yeah and I'm The Rook is going to lift
itself up over to the B4 square and then
he's going to line up both books on the
B line yeah
I think you're right about that one
Ivanka Black's King is coming but
Black's King cannot really go too much
further
um at some points if it does March
towards those white pawns it will either
get cut off or it will get checked away
kings are good at marching towards Pawns
in Solo Rook end games when it's just
one Rook each but if it's double Rook
end games
then yeah King struggled to approach
pawns unfortunately and Prague he
doesn't look as kind of focused as
confident as he has in previous games
and he knows he is losing this one he'll
have to strike back again with white
he's done it once already you'll need to
do it again and we have a draw between
Magnus Carlsen and Liam Lane game three
that means they will be tied before game
four and that's gonna be white pieces
for Liam black pieces for Magnus in that
final game of the day well could be a
final day game of the day if we have a
winner in that game if it's a draw then
it means tie breaks wow drama in that
one but this one is looking good for
Duda
about to win against Prague
yep and I like what Prague has done so
earlier we were talking about Rooks
behind past pawns at least like what
Prague has done with his Rook on the B1
Square uh and now the Rook of the B
Falls Square because he's behind he's
controlling the white pawns
um unfortunately he's two pawns down so
this isn't going to save the game but
just as an instructive example that's
where Rooks belong in general behind
passports it's a good technique but like
you say it's not gonna help it's not
going to help and this is a very nice
move from Duda he's just sealing the win
he's basically and there you go he's so
satisfied with himself because he's won
the game
wow and imagine when he checks uh
results in the other ones young
Christoph dude are now up in the match
against frag and he's gonna know that
Magnus will have to win game four